i'm like [ __ ] you just admit that oh
my god we're going to do so many
push-ups listen we were all standing on
we were all standing by our butt you did
not say that dead ass you did that dead
ass
i'll never forget this
this orange county sheriff's deputy has
been punished for a video she posted on
tick tock yet despite the punishment she
continues to create new videos while
wearing her uniform
now the deputy was suspended from her
job for disobeying her superiors and
discrediting the sheriff's office but
tonight the deputy continues to post new
tick tock videos news 6 investigator
mike deforest shows us why she is doing
it
this investigation began when a fellow
deputy stumbled upon the tick tock
videos during the investigation other
law enforcement officers said they felt
the videos were inappropriate and
embarrassing orange county deputy shelby
abramson received a three-week
suspension after investigators say she
violated agency policy while posting
videos on tick tock so when you're
looking at my belt i have a taser
and i have a
gun
only one gun honey
what did you say i like these on a gun
and i only have one gun honey some
people i guess assume it's two guns
because they see the both holsters not
realizing it's just one
can i just appreciate that she had her
lights on her car while she was filming
this tick tock
yeah because the person just told her
stage what you gonna do this with your
two guns she said let me go to texas
hold on let me just let me just educate
you and the rest of the people all right
it's two guns
watch for your
head man listen attention is a crazy
currency everybody wants all of it just
fine
but let's keep watching a little bit
more abramson has been creating
tick-tock videos of herself in uniform
since shortly after she was hired by the
agency less than two years ago those
tick tock videos have earned her 80
thousand followers
according to this internal report
although most of the videos deputy
abramson posted were benign some of the
audio tracks contain foul language and
sexually explicit lyrics
the school resource officer deleted this
video after news 6 first reported about
it telling investigators she screwed up
and shouldn't have posted that one
besides placing the sheriff's office in
disrepute
imagine this is your first day of
med you you're a cop you're gonna be on
the force for 10 years your new partner
is her she's like oh wait listen before
we make another risk can i just
yeah if i'm with my partner new job yes
who's this freeze not for the gun for
the camera
freeze can you do the one tip challenge
how are we supposed to take you
seriously when you're behaving like a
[ __ ] teenager as a matter of fact
it's not come on now you're a grown
woman it's not you're on the job if you
want to do that off the job that's fine
but here okay that's the take that's a
new take but it's like there's a bunch
of nurses that do the same thing what a
bunch of nerves that do tick-tock videos
a lot of them get fired yeah of course
yeah you know why because they
[ __ ] dying
but [ __ ] what the [ __ ] you doing
bro people want attention so bad they'd
be documenting every part of their life
they'd be documenting stuff while it's
happening rather than dealing with
what's happening it's like that tick
tock of the girl who
was at her date's place decided to film
a tick tock be like where's my date
[ __ ] go find out why are you telling
the whole world what you gonna do but
people are live streaming everything
because they just want that attention
yeah oh i'm here with the beautiful girl
i don't know if she likes me like the
[ __ ] is right in front of you just ask
her
why are you asking the whole world
and you have to imagine she's in uniform
you don't represent yourself anymore no
it's time we learn in the military it's
like [ __ ] you better watch how you act
in uniform and off uniform because at
the end of the day you represent us when
you [ __ ] up and you commit a crime it's
going to say armed forces sergeant
general whatever it might be okay saint
john so let me show you do you know that
city of course
i live
saint johnson
you know that how why did you live there
because that's where you do basically
that's where you do basic training when
you're in the forces all right and i
could tell you one thing not the
military but the people from saint
johnson
and you can attest to this or not this
is
hate military of course
of course let me let me let me tell you
guys why do they hate military let me
tell you what happens
when you get shipped off the basic right
you're basically stuck in this little
base you can't leave you can't see
family you can call them but that's the
best you can do yeah until about week
six of your training and then they say
you can leave base you could go and have
some fun but
their sergeants look at you they say
listen you guys go home for the weekend
do whatever you want but by sunday 10
p.m we're gonna do roll call so you
better be here and also careful how you
act out there
why do they say that because they know
all that pent up frustration being
around dudes all day long gotta mow your
money in your bank account young dumb
full of [ __ ] okay
it's about to go down and let me tell
you roll call came around people were
missing people arrived but they weren't
completely there i saw a dude come back
full of cocaine binge i saw a dude come
back full of cocaine [ __ ] sergeant said
what the [ __ ] wrong with you sorry
sergeant i was late because uh i was
doing cocaine off the strippers back i'm
like [ __ ] you just admit that oh my
god we're going to do so many push-ups
listen we were all standing on we were
all standing by our bum you did not say
that dead ass you did that dead ass dad
hey i'll never forget this okay he was
he was he he was from a small town i
think he did too many mushrooms because
he was kind of cooked
we were awesome by our books okay
i'll never get private fletcher okay
that's probably i'll never forget this
day we're all sitting by our bunks i
didn't i had attention ready for
inspection marcie talk about my fire
team partner his shit's all put away so
we're just waiting and we can hear him
making the rounds around the barracks
and we hear him like private fletcher
what the [ __ ] is going on
what why do you look like this and he's
like sorry sergey said why were you late
private
uh
sergeant i made a mistake one mistake
private
i was doing i was doing blow off a
hooker's back
what did i tell you we were all like at
attention and then we all stopped like
you're not supposed you're not supposed
to move
so we all just went what the [ __ ] did he
just say and we knew we were [ __ ] and
you know what was crazy the thing was so
shocking to everybody even the sergeant
didn't reply he left the room went to go
get the other staff members they all
came back and they all like i need to
hear this [ __ ]
okay they they weren't out here they
were mad but i can tell they're like i
need to see this for myself
i'll be back yeah so you saw four people
come up and they said repeat what you
just said
that you heard them just dream his ass
investigators say the deputy disobeyed
her supervisor by continuing to create
tick-tock videos while on duty despite
being ordered to stop so we're going to
do some squat talks with shelby abramson
defended her tick-tock videos to
investigators saying her motive was the
humanizing of the badge that we're not
just this bad guy behind a gun
[Music]
while the sheriff's internal probe was
still underway abramson continued to
post tick-tock videos including one
recorded inside epcot while the park was
empty morning do not add 30 pounds try
this dance even after being punished she
has kept on making new tick tock videos
for her online fans the orange county
sheriff's office would not make abramson
available for an interview and she told
news 6 by phone that her supervisors
instructed her not to speak with us
some law enforcement agencies prohibit
officers from appearing in uniform on
their personal social media accounts now
the orange county sheriff's office does
allow it but deputies are cautioned
against identifying the agency and they
must not do anything that would
negatively impact the public's
perception of the agency
i'm not i'm not going to do an interview
they said not to contact them but i can
do it on tick-tock
yeah you're wild people are so close
your attention listen to your friends
you are wild you're wildin and you know
you're gonna see just more of this you
know people taking pictures of them at
the morgue working with bodies like
they'll find ways to disrespect stuff
irrespective of how other folks feel
about it so you know this is this is a
new social media age nothing is private
even on the job nothing is professional
people do whatever the [ __ ] that they
want it's it's wild it's wild and
me watching this
some people might not get it like oh you
know she wants to humanize the badge and
make police officers seem more
personable and yes while the intentions
may be good the way that you're doing it
matters as well you also make the whole
industry look unprofessional
you're supposed to be on the job
serving protecting and instead you're
doing live streams on facebook instead
you're basically
doing whatever you want because it makes
you more personable that's not your job
your job is to serve and protect people
finding when you're doing using tax
dollars to go to disney while it's
closed and do tick-tock dance that's wow
like that how does that wow
maybe the kids enjoy it and maybe the
kids laugh grown adults who pay taxes
don't find that [ __ ] funny no they look
at that and they're like do your [ __ ]
job
do your [ __ ] job because every time i
see you all in person y'all be on some
[ __ ] so do your job
i wanna be seeing you on social media
doing some [ __ ] and look cops drove
their credit a lot of them do a great
job cool fantastic but yeah you see some
[ __ ] like that it makes you look at them
funny
100
and i know if i was any cop on the force
and i had to be partnered with her i'd
be like this [ __ ] ain't serious about
her [ __ ] she's more concerned with likes
and all this stuff and how she's
perceived than actually serving and
protected
no
if you want to take on that kind of
mantra have a discussion with your
department make curated stuff but you
can't just do whatever the [ __ ] you want
you're part of a unit you're part of a
whole you're part of ensemble you're not
individual when you're part of a company
you don't get to say i'm going to take
control of our marketing
i'm going to be the one who decides how
we're going to be perceived and make my
own content representing our company no
company would ever accept that they
would fire your ass
real quick take off the uniform maybe we
can have a different discussion you bet
you doing that in uniform get [ __ ] all
right well what do you think about the
whole thing well you said a whole lot
that was pretty much that you know
whether it whether it's law enforcement
whether it's nurses wonder it might be
cute on the beginning but at some point
i'm gonna look at your videos and be
like
yeah um there was a robbery i called you
guys three hours ago what were you doing
tick tocks you know what i mean that is
gonna [ __ ] with my head whenever i'm
gonna go get some service whenever i go
get i'm gonna go to the hospital and
something's gonna be wrong i'm like so
what is it tick-tock and you're gonna
discredit the rest of your co-workers
that are not doing that it's not just
you and it's not just the force but
people are gonna not just look at you
it's the whole [ __ ] force
everybody's gonna be subjected to that
just the same way that if one [ __ ] up
everybody [ __ ] up right so yeah it's
bad it's bad on the people that didn't
want that attention there's some cops
that just want to do their [ __ ] job
and it's already hard to do their
[ __ ] job and people already hate them
you know there's no such thing as [ __ ]
the fireball department no it's [ __ ] the
police right people don't like that [ __ ]
right
it's already hard as it is right now
you want to add like a layer to that
like a tick top
it's like
you're 29 not 19b
you're doing a zombie job what
like
back in the day we used to make fun of
cops because they were eating too many
donuts and people would see them at the
[ __ ] donut shop all the time like yo
[ __ ] drop the donuts that's why there
used to be a pejorative thing for like
lazy cops that we perceived as a matter
of fact
here in quebec there was the comedy
group called uh
ebenzare whatever it doesn't matter but
they made a song
a funny song with a video called bonjour
la police hello cops right
and basically bonjour la palis was
written
in dunkin donuts funds right
and
they were like eating donuts and [ __ ]
like that and being stupid cops right
and and every time the cops were getting
pulled over what cops were pulling over
people people started saying bonjour
police they used to say
they got
they the the police did did not go to
dunkin donuts they were not allowed to
be seen at dunkin donuts yeah as a
matter of fact
it was when tim hortons was starting to
be beat okay and then
thinking donuts looking back over here
but but i didn't think even dunkin
donuts you're not really going to see a
cop there because of that because of a
song
that people that were not in the police
made about the police and donuts
cops were not allowed to be seen at
dunkin donuts
that's [ __ ] up
so imagine if you're the one you're the
perpetrator you're the one that's doing
all these things dances and [ __ ]
it's gonna have an effect yeah yeah
100 so
there you guys have it let us know what
you guys think in the comments below we
want to hear from you
at epcot at night while it's that's wild